[Musique]
le charme enivrant du désert a le
pouvoir d' exacerber du patient
je vous pose la question
[Musique]
avez vous déjà aimé aussi fort
avez vous été en proie à la jalousie au
point de tuer un meurtre a été commis
l'assassin est l'un d'entre vous je ne
me sens pas en sécurité
je ne suis en sécurité avec aucun de stu
j'ai mené de nombreuses enquêtes
criminelles me mais celle ci c
restera à jamais gravé dans mon âme je
suis le détective hercule poirot et je
vais vous livrer la salle
combien de grandes histoires
ce sont des tragédies
[Musique]
tous ces tests sont terminées chez moi
confiance je dois beaucoup à ton père et
je lui ai promis de te ramener chez toi
avant minuit alors on y va
nous n'avons pas encore toutes les
réponses concernant les événements
survenus à moscou il ya deux ans mais
aujourd'hui nous mettons tous nos
efforts en commun pour nous assurer
qu'aucun objet d'identifier ne puisse
plus jamais arriver sur notre planète
le poids du sud et j'habite à coucher
les rouges à votre adresse complète mon
adresse complète super constellation de
la vierge galaxie voisine de la voie
lactée bras d'orion système solaire
planète terre tu as tort s'il te plaît
ne résiste pas je ne veux pas te faire
du mal elle est dans une voiture avec un
homme noir
ils sont reliés
ioulia tué en danger maintenant le
regard et je te croyais mort
plus tôt tu dois t'en volet le plus vite
possible
il a donné l'ordre de tirer vous n'avez
pas la parole général est notre seule
clé d'accès à ces technologies
vie est en danger elle n'est plus comme
joue maintenant ses nouveaux pouvoirs
peuvent être une menace pour tout le
monde
tu peux revenir chez toi mais elle doit
être éliminé il va peut-être mourir à
cause de toi
qu'est ce que vous préférez
le monde ma fille alors toi
[Musique]
nous sommes des intrus et nous devons
nous sauver les uns les autres par tous
les moyens
ma
mais moi c'est quelle planète que tu
défendes
salut mais vous est resplendissante
bonjour tu laisses avalanche de vote net
ça va merci va mieux et quoi j'aime les
conquêtes 1 je travaille beaucoup il est
tout le temps en déplacement avec des
clients et moi et là rabat joie de
service qui va faire des plannings chien
blanc alors bis mais souvent voyage dont
il part pour le boulot on arrête lever
la main si vous trouvez ça ford 10 n'a
rien à voir avec toi c'est un gentil
gars un père génial ça me c'est sa
nature
les mâles doit lutter s'ils veulent
dominer et féconde et toutes les
familles
[Musique]
peut-être que mon mari ne s'intéressent
plus à moi par aussi c'est toute une
famille est au sommet de sa beauté entre
l'âge de 35 et de 39 ans en fait il me
reste plein de moi phoenix est autant
dire que tu travailles beaucoup et plein
de trucs on voit ton mari devrait
générer le solde dû fouler mais s'il se
conduit mal c'est important qu'il sache
et si jamais on découvrait tout digne
tout simplement débordés je crois qu'on
devrait tenter une filature
il vaudrait mieux que tulle ou en
actions c'est ça ce que tu appelles être
agonique d'eau
[Musique]
viendra de là c'est dans ce palace qui
trompe c'est celui qui a le plus de
sorties il y en a sur trois rues
est ce que c'est on irait d'avoir l'air
juste un peu moins enthousiaste parce
qu'il s'agit de ma vie là et elle était
en train de tomber en volume
je sais pas pourquoi des femmes pour la
chirurgie esthétique pour pierre aux
hommes dans ton genre je lèverai faire
avec les pièces d'origine
ouais et quelle que soit la marque et le
modèle merci je vais prendre ça comme un
compliment
il y en a bien deux euros j'ai eu peur
l'interface est activée nous sommes à
pleine puissance ont servi au niveau
équipement
vous assurez vous de puits et sur la
tête entrant sortant une fois la liaison
établie pas de retour en arrière
aucune perte de contrôle n'est permise
durant l'exécution pouvons nous
permettre aucune erreur
fait
10 bien très bien d'accord maintenant
arrêter réglisse à 2
[Musique]
lou
oh
fonction d un truc pour vieux t'as rien
perdu tu as tous les mouvements
je te croyais mort et enterré bah moi
aussi frenchy crois moi mais je te
raconterai plus tard deux jours trois
clients ni vu ni connu le testant dit
t'es sérieux ouais ouais ouais c'est
quoi ça c'est propre c'est silencieux et
ça sent pas le fauve à l'intérieur
d'accord
suivez-moi ce représentant de chaussures
anglaises et au courant de qui je suis
si le fric est prêt et toi tu nous le
donne
c'est quoi ton problème elle nous a filé
fric trop facilement à mon goût j'en ai
plus que marre d'être violent c'est
terminé allez vas-y mappus a rappelé
bon bah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au bonjour à tous
n'avez vous jamais été invité un peu si
des versions village people aux années
c'est pas les magouilles je t'avais pas
coupé on peut pas dire ma couille sur
les chaînes basique du câble vous êtes
pareils à la maison oh non on s'entend
pas aussi bien à la maison lui j'adore
tous vos livres et vous triez
pouvons-nous faire une trêve
oui enfin enfin quand as tu déjà demandé
une trêve
tu réalises que tu commences une dispute
à propos d'une traîne cher héros smur
voici ton petit fils tu as un petit fils
c'est incroyable je me suis même pas
fait retoucher il se rendait il est où
là que le mot il est en prison et le
gamin va vivre ici où veux tu qu'ils ont
peut pas garder un enfant on n'a même
pas su gérer cette saloperie de
yorkshire terrier
je vis avec paul erasmus ils sont gais
ya certains modes vous ne devez jamais
utilisé quand vous parler à une personne
qui est gay ne jamais dire ta soeur ne
jamais dire suceurs de queen méliscènes
white des services de protection de
l'enfance
pourriez-vous venir tous les deux s'il
vous plaît seixois aux fantômes as
il a traversé une période assez intense
j'étais fan de sabre laser à poil en
montagne d'autant plus ici que le
matériau ressources est également gay
est ce que tu as deux paires c'est un
peu ça je serais sorti avant son bilan
ici moi je veux rester écoute bien tu
partiras nulle part
ces premiers et si tu promets de ne pas
vendre cette drogue
on donnera 100 $ par semaine
[Musique]
tu as le plus gros coeur de tous les
hommes que je connaisse
[Musique]
on va tout bazarder de manière ils sont
sur le net ou est ce que j'ai dit ça va
[Musique]
est ce qu'en fait la nature n'est qu'un
chat gigantesque et si oui qui lui
caresse le doux
permettez moi de vous présenter le
brillant nikola tesla s'est réellement
le plus grande quant aux google nikola
tesla on obtient 34 millions de résultat
en gros ce sont les mêmes quatre photos
on trouve aussi des infos étranges ou
même farfelue par à aider si vous avez
un briquet tesla ne vous avais pas vus
et maintenant j'ai l'immense plaisir de
vous présenter un tout nouveau système
d'énergie le courant alternatif
mon système va transformer le
fonctionnement du mantra d'étincelles
c'est parfait où vous cachez vous le
courant alternatif est une perte de
temps de pratique est morte elle vivait
dans votre tête
comme tout le monde tu manques de
financements monsieur tesla considère
que je lui dois de l'argent par deux
fois cinquante milles de là d'accord
annequin la fille de jay peak pente
morgan
une femme comme celle-là peut rendre
possible tes rêves les plus fous
murray faisant possible je vous offre
une limonade vous travaillez la nuit
dans un laboratoire secret vous projetez
des éclairs à partir de la terre
jusqu'au 6 c'est comme si j'essaie
d'apprivoiser un chat sauvage et que je
me retrouvais couvert d'égratignures
sanglante
vous aimez être griffes et si nécessaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans lequel nous vivons fait partie d'un
rêve qui était ce là à rêver le premier
[Musique]